el norte y el sur vuelven a quedar
divididos esta vez es el proceso de
vacunación que dibuja una frontera
sanitaria y política entre los dos lados
del continente americano
en el norte eeuu avanza con rapidez su
proceso de vacunación en el sur hay
países que ni siquiera han recibido la
vacuna
especialmente desde la llegada de joe
biden a la presidencia de eeuu el país
ha acelerado la campaña de inmunización
ya ha inyectado más de 65 millones de
dosis de los fármacos 6 veces más que
todas las aplicadas en américa del sur y
aunque países como brasil y méxico
también han inoculado millones de
vacunas la cifra se queda pequeña en
proporción a su población en realidad
solo chile y eeuu han aplicado más de 15
dosis de vacunas por 100 habitantes les
siguen brasil y canadá aunque a
distancia méxico y argentina no alcanzan
las 2 dosis por cada 100 personas y la
mayoría de países como colombia o perú
ni siquiera llegan a una dosis por cada
100 personas
además hay otros países que todavía no
han recibido ni una vacuna especialmente
en centroamérica muchos como haití
guatemala honduras depende enteramente
del mecanismo kóvacs para iniciar la
inmunización de sus poblaciones
'cuba en cambio no importa vacunas
porque está desarrollando cuatro
fármacos propios
muchos de los gobiernos han recibido
críticas por la lentitud de sus campañas
de inmunización y aunque son varios los
países que ya tienen acuerdos de compra
con las farmacéuticas muchas compañías
apenas se alcanzan a entregar los
pedidos que hicieron antes los países
occidentales
mientras tanto la población
latinoamericana espera impaciente su
turno en un orden mundial que los relega
a un segundo lugar